i'm married the best rapper of all time
if that clip from kanye west's donda 2
listening event sounds familiar that's
because it's a sample of his estranged
wife kim kardashian on saturday night
live i'm married the best rapper of all
time on tuesday the grammy winner played
a portion of kim's snl monologue from
october during his event at lone depot
park in miami he's the richest black man
in america a talented legit genius who
gave me four incredible kicks now it's
worth noting the sampling cuts off
before kim jokes about divorcing kanye
when i divorced him you have to know it
came down to just one thing
his personality yay previously addressed
all that during an interview with drink
champs in november snl making my wife
say i divorced him on tv because they
just wanted to get that bar off and i
ain't never even seen the papers we not
even divorced
so how we
cause that ain't no joke to me but it's
hardly the first time the rapper has
incorporated the skim's founder into his
live shows
back in december he changed the lyrics
to his hit run away
and in august kim rocked a balenciaga
wedding gown for her cameo during
kanye's donda event in chicago
he's done miracles on me
but kim wasn't at the event on tuesday
which isn't really surprising given that
the two have been at odds publicly
feuding on social media amid their
ongoing divorce i'm just extremely happy
can you tell by my face
meanwhile things are getting more and
more serious between kim and pete
davidson the 41 year old's reality star
started dating the comedian shortly
after her snl hosting gig i like you
just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
kanye has taken aim at kim's new beau in
several since deleted posts to social
media and on the track easy
but a source previously told et that
pete is trying to stay out of the drama
between the former couple adding that
he's been trying to disassociate from
kanye as much as possible and ignore his
rants
pete knows it's not his place to be too
involved even though he is being dragged
through the mud he doesn't care he just
wants to be there for kim and support
her he genuinely cares so much about her
and their relationship i love that that
energy in my life and another
relationship pete cares about is the one
he has with his girlfriend's friends and
family
i love that e.t source previously
explained that kim and pete have gotten
even closer in the last few weeks and
the king of staten island star has been
going out of his way to connect with
kim's crew quote he wants the family to
know that it's not just a fling between
him and kim and that it is way deeper
than that
and when eti chatted with kim's bestie
jonathan cheban last week he weighed in
on their love i think it's cool you know
what she's having fun i guess you know
uh you know i i've hung out with them a
couple of times and you know i love her
to death so whatever whatever makes her
happy
[Music]
you